so this year is like the similar movies
year we've already had Olympus has
fallen in white house down this is the
end and now the worlds end this is the
end is one of the funniest movies I've
seen all year does the world's and even
compare the worlds end is directed by
Edgar Wright and star Simon Pegg Nick
Frost
Martin Freeman and some other really
talented British actors and this is kind
of like the unofficial conclusion to the
unofficial trilogy that started with
Shaun of the Dead and then Hot Fuzz and
now the World's End in this movie simon
Pegg's character his name is Gary King
and him and his friends from high school
get together to do the Golden Mile it's
this challenge from their home town
where they have to go on this mile
filled with pubs and on each pub they
get a pint of beer and they drink it the
last pub is the World's End it's his big
challenge not too many people have been
able to do it and when they were in high
school they weren't able to complete it
so they all get back together for one
more night of trying to do it lo and
behold there is some seriously messed-up
stuff going on in this town involving a
bit of a hostile takeover from some
otherworldly beings now I was really
excited for the World's End because I
loved Edgar Wright he's one of my
favorite directors Simon Pegg and Nick
Frost are absolutely hilarious to me
I love Shaun of the Dead I loved Hot
Fuzz and I was truly hoping this was
going to be one of my favorite films of
the summer and I got to say guys it is
my favorite film on the summer the world
end is incredibly great I love this film
from start to finish not one single dull
moment this is the kind of movie I have
been wanting to see all summer where it
just delivered and it gave me everything
I wanted and more and I love this movie
so much it was so clever it was so well
written I mean I was gut-busting
laughing so many times throughout this
movie and I'm just gonna stop gushing
right now and try to talk civilized
about this movie I can't it's awesome I
love this but it's so good I am
fanboying out over this movie I'm not
even kidding like the direction this
movie is so Swift and so solid remember
half Scott Pilgrim just all of a sudden
have these amazing fight scenes you
weren't expecting similiar to the
World's End there are so many great
action scenes in this movie all directed
well Edgar Wright's signature way of
filming things you know zum-zum zum-zum
zum-zum zum-zum cut cut cut cut really
fast editing in a good way
okay I'm not talking about quick cut
idiocy I'm talking about a lot of
terrific cinematography cut together in
a way where you literally if you missile
the second of this movie you could not
even understand the entire joke that
they're trying to tell or you can miss a
whole plot point because you're not
paying attention and that's one of the
things that I love about this movie you
are forced to pay attention I hate
movies that give you those moments to
cool down or those moments to breathe or
whatever pay attention to every scene be
on in every scene from scene one and
this movie is the first scene this movie
is so fantastic it's this great parody
on the 90s you see like certain titles
that look just like something off of an
old 1990s television show that's on MTV
I adored it it was just such a cool way
to start this movie Simon Pegg was on
fire in this movie almost everything out
of his mouth was comedy gold every times
I was just like huh like I was just
trying to like catch my breath from how
awesomely hilarious this movie was Nick
Frost was so good in this movie he
played this kind of reserved character
who eventually starts to break out of
his shell and watching that happen was
just great now one of the things I loved
about this movie was as the night goes
on and as these more intense encounters
with these otherworldly beings continue
to rise they get more drunk and more
drunk and more drunk and that added so
much this movie because it was so
fast-paced that you had to keep up with
them and from scene to scene you could
see okay they're getting more and more
drunk and it added so much to their
characters comedy and the way the actors
portrayed it was just it was flawless
everyone was just absolutely terrific in
this movie one of the things I loved
about this movie is that the shit
doesn't really hit the fan too like a
half hour in you may think well were you
bored until those stuff started
happening not at all because it was just
so cleverly written and so beautifully
filmed that it was like I could have
watched the rest of the movie without
the whole otherworldly being alien thing
going on like I could have just watched
the rest of the movie that way and I
would have been perfectly fine with it
the characters will well realize there's
so many great little in jokes in there
if you watch Hot Fuzz on Shaun of the
Dead this is definitely a fitting
conclusion to this for me I adored this
film I honestly don't really have any
problems with this movie I loved each of
the characters all the actors were so
fantastic
their roles the special effects were a
lot of fun the fight scenes were awesome
the cinematography was great there were
so many long takes in the movie some of
it was blended together with clever
editing but it all just looked fantastic
everything about this movie was exactly
what I needed it is finally the film
that I have been waiting for this summer
where I can legitimately say the world's
end gets an A plus guys if you're fan of
Hot Fuzz if you're a fan of Shaun of the
Dead go out and see this movie you will
love it even if you don't like those
movies just go see it deserves your
money because these guys are making the
kind of movies I need to see more of in
theaters Thank You Edgar right you are
awesome so guys when you see the movie
let me know your thoughts I'm very
interested in by the way what do you
like more hot fuzz or Shaun of the Dead
I think I'm a Hot Fuzz kind of guy
maybe Shawn's dad kind of guy maybe like
I'm not the same I don't know they're
both great and as always guys thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes